fait le petit mot douves par excellence
un petit texte qui accompagne un
chocolat ça fait deux bonnes raisons de
s'intéresser aux papillotes une
spécialité lyonnaise qui a une très
vieille histoire histoire que nous
raconte céline crespy et frédéric botton
pour éclairer les tables de noël à lyon
il y a toujours des papillotes un
chocolat qui a plus de deux siècles une
tradition régionale issue d'une
charmante petite histoire d'amour bien
sur papier est né au xviiie siècle aiea
lyon dans le quartier des terreaux c'est
sûr papillaud qui avait un comique il
est volé des chocolats enrobé de petits
mots doux pour correspondre avec sarah
son amoureuse doux sur tapis your hat on
idée parce que c'était une super bonne
idée mais il n'a pas gardé le ekomy
amoureux il a conservé l'idée avec donc
un papier un petit mot doux en chocolat
c'est en 1898 que deux entrepreneurs
lyonnais fabrique des papillotes en
grande quantité la tradition est née
lusine fourneaux mais le chocolat
destinés aux soldats pendant la première
guerre mondiale
mais dans les années 50 la papillote
chocolat populaire est réputé de
mauvaise qualité pour survivre la marque
doit alors créer de véritables recettes
chocolatière des recettes qui évolue
perpétuellement aujourd'hui la tendance
s'est beaucoup d'inclusion dans l'est et
dans les moments de chocolat les gens
aiment bien le côté craquant les
brisures de biscuits les trains d'amendé
choses comme ça et on revient à suez au
traditionnel aussi avec les pâtes
d'amande les prévienne épure allemande
des pralinés pure à la noisette du
chocolat on n'en fabrique plus de 1500
tonnes chaque noël dans cette usine de
la région roannaise
mais la papillote c'est bien plus que
cela
lee à la recette du bonbon qui est très
importante
et puis après il ya aussi le papier qui
doit être très très coloré rangée avec
le rébus qui sert à transporter
une petite anecdote une citation exemple
de philosophie papilles aux tiers quelle
est la différence entre un amant et un
mari et bien c'est le jour et la nuit à
méditer en savourant ce et papillotes
qui titilleront vos papilles
depuis